so today's topic the caster Semenya case
have you all know where casts min years
of advant and barred from competing in
any olympic races and national level
races
she's been bad for the races until she
takes meds to lower her naturally
produce testosterone yeah this case is
drawn a lot of criticism a lot of
different reactions I mean please
disagree on this so please what are your
thoughts to me it doesn't really add up
she's just being a woman her her body is
naturally producing that testosterone
that enables her to beat the Olympics is
supposed to be a place where you're
supposed to celebrate the natural
performance of the body that's what the
Olympics is okay and they're supposed to
ban any kind of drugs to an answer body
or to change your body any kind of
weight she's naturally producing that's
that's wrong and that's what the
Olympics and all those sports is
supposed to celebrate and we're banning
them no no no you're too strong on the
other side Michael Phelps is a wonder of
the world and his body is able to
produce less lactic acid therefore his
body this isn't hurt and he doesn't get
fatigued as much as we can and he's been
celebrated they didn't ask him to take
more drugs so that his body can produce
more acid lactic like the rest of the
competed anyways there's a lot of
discrepancies a lot of double standard
that you have with the lab thing that's
pretty much what I have to say about
that first I want to start by saying
caster Semenya and the way she's handle
this whole situation extremely classy oh
I've never see someone and drew so much
really kill so much hate so much
nonsense just for being herself and she
never left Sun even Lester she won the
latest race after she said that she was
going to refuse to take the medication
which means she was never gonna Reese
again even after all that and the
interview der she said I don't know the
day it's all about inspiring you know
the world you know showing the world
that you know
it's possible if you believe what
happens for you now I keep training I
keep running so doesn't matter if
something comes in front of me like I
said I always find a way to come you
know jump it when I see that to me she's
already someone who I think is amazing
salute okay
regardless of what I think about this
now this issue is not her about being a
woman or man it this is about being male
or female and caster Semenya like two
percent of the population of the world
falls under the intersex category all
right and so you know when you have X Y
chromosome and X X chromosome X Y being
male X Y being female caster Semenya
falls under XY DSD which stands for
definitely the right we're safe or
developmental sexual disorder and what
that means is that for some people who
fall under this chromosome she's a
female she has a genitalia but she has
an X Y chromosome and so it makes it
very ambiguous in regards to where her
testosterone levels are some people will
say well Michael Phelps has you know
larger lats and he has these different
things within his body and and then the
same bolt has other genetic aspects that
make it advantageous for them the
problem is the Olympics and most
governing bodies do not divide races and
different sports by wingspan or by
length they avoid by women and women men
you know exactly and then they have
these males against testosterone because
they recognize how much it amplifies
people's ability to win and so for
caster Semenya she has a genetic makeup
that's hard to place into any one
category and she also has AI extra
testosterone boost which definitely
gives her significant advantage and so
when you categorize these things and
someone doesn't fall in that category
it's difficult to say is it okay or is
it not obtained at the end of the day
it's unfair to somebody it's unfair to
intersex people it's unfair to women
were naturally born with XX chromosomes
and as someone who thinks she's amazing
and thinks what she's done for a country
inspiring people is amazing it's also
very tough for me to say maybe me
either right oh yeah even though I think
they're trash in a lot of their rulings
I think they may be right on this one
even if she wants to take the medication
that may not be enough because I didn't
this she's going to whole life with
these testosterone boost and this
genetic advantage that if you take the
medication and suppress and now your
body's already acclimated your bone
density is already shifted the way you
look the way you ask you are your muscle
twitch fibers everything has been
augmented by this boost from the top you
know it's why some people and I myself
included believe that there should be a
lifetime ban for people who take ghd and
all these kinds of supplements that
complete modify your body even if you
stop taking it and you start to race
you've already had the benefits
absolutely I have to admit my double
standard the only reason I'm for this
girl is because she's not fighting if it
was fighting I'd be like because are you
putting other people's because now
you're putting someone's life in danger
in danger because now you have different
bone density different muscle mass
different all of that is different which
is what makes this whole thing difficult
so on hand I'm rooting for her on the
other I understand why she's barred and
you know Sports is unfair and inherently
genetically were not equal you know what
I mean I play basketball someone seven
foot five all these things they alter us
I know they give us advantage I don't
swim Kevin Durant is a seven-foot
monster that could shoot jump shots he's
unstoppable genetically he's a [ __ ]
freak right but I enjoy watching that
freak play personally I want castor to
be able to race because I enjoy watching
free-to-play and not even like in an
insulting way every sport that's played
at the highest level is a freakin
together bunch of people around and go
through any NBA team see that watch
there's [ __ ] team photos you're
talking about Giants who dribble a
basketball they're not a normal ordinary
people slam dunk contest is the freak
show okay and I want to see that that's
my personal taste but I understand the
rules that are in place and why they're
in place in the categories by which they
categorize people and therefore I
understand why she has been and I think
there's no easy answer and I think
people want to be easy answers it's
complicated the science is complicated
and so I would just tell everyone to
really research before they comment on
this thing
because that's what this topic you
haven't lived and you haven't researched
and you're just basing your [ __ ] on
emotion I really don't want to hear you
play I think it's good though that our
he's now having to ask these questions
that we started recognizing all the
different forms that sex and gender can
take place in because now we have to
have the more difficult conversations
about what are these differences how do
they influence us how do they make us
better or worse how do we even out the
playing field in different ways and so I
think we're just at a time right now
where things are very blurry where
things everyone thought everything was
binary they're realizing it's much more
complicated this yeah and we are having
to have these discussions so that's the
positive so good let's have that and
take it you know to cast a shadow too I
mean because I think I think you're
amazing
yes and nothing about this ruling or any
of that whatever change time and I think
if anything you're probably gonna become
bigger simple knowledge she is yeah
she's the first case she but she's the
first not only that she's the first less
you said before she is the most humble
yeah cuz I would have dealt with that
[ __ ] like that no you know me yeah I
would have yeah you get mad for nothing
whoa [ __ ] up [ __ ] [ __ ] you I wouldn't
deal like I wouldn't deal with that
situation with the class that she's
dealing with that situation so yo shout
outs to you boo boo shout outs to you
and so yeah that's pretty much it for
today's video tell us what you guys
think
[Music]